goddamn Ainsley I need I'm out of ideas
again I could just come up with an idea
but that would be ridiculous when I can
just do whatever all right let's see
what cancer is in the recommended tab no
wrong hard mind trick test 98% fail that
seems to be a thing that's going just
add a percentage of a fail I think I
lied that on all my videos from now on
the fail represents how many people
would actually want watch this video
past three seconds let's see if we can
do it oh my god it's so easy to see you
now
enter this month's $100 gift card give 9
seconds hey that's longer than I thought
enter this month's $100 gift card
giveaway all you have to do let me guess
leave a like leave a like subscribe
subscribe sell soul to Satan turn
notifications on oh [ __ ] okay alright
don't forget about the notification have
you bailed my channel yet by the way I
put a pie you always make fun of our
youtubers you don't understand you don't
understand there's so much [ __ ] [ __ ]
on YouTube these days I have to it is my
job it is my duty at this point to call
this [ __ ] up I don't even do you think I
actually care no I do not and if you
want even more stuff check the
description down below for an extra
giveaway there's more there is more are
you telling me there is more gotta check
the description for more
what it's not even available you lie you
lie to me dis supported just support why
is this the state of YouTube that what
whoever gets the best thumbnail and the
longest video and you're fine and it's
all these pimply as teenagers okay just
go away just got no one likes you okay
you need to be moderately attractive
like jacksepticeye and markiplier
otherwise yeah what we're taking a look
at are some mind tricks so good luck
whoa whoa whoa whoa whoa whoa Oh an
original thought just came to my mind
I'm going to make hardest mind-trick
test 99% fail okay let's do this
together try not to get mind trick
challenge only 99 percent can beat it
are you part of the 1% let's play a log
take a look at the image below what do
you see I see a man grasping a woman's
tits I see a nice a nice water bottle
and inside two ghosts are [ __ ] each
other focus on the following picture and
give a quick answer which stairs will
you use to go up and which will go down
doesn't matter it yeah you the thing
that's the thing about stairs you can go
up and you can go down them I know it is
crazy
my mind is blown right now Jesus Christ
are you telling me are you telling me
that there's an equal amount of stairs
going up as there is stairs going down
no [ __ ] way
no [ __ ] no [ __ ] way out of juice I
refuse to be there there's a man's head
somewhere in this picture find it I
don't even want to say it because I'm so
offended this one is cool I really like
this one because for me right now she's
going clockwise what about you guys I
really like this one if you really focus
you can make her change direction while
you're looking at it always remember
your focus determines your reality
oh she spent she spins the other
direction now I looked at the head oh
now she's been back what the [ __ ]
now she's spinning what's happening ah
oh oh dude this is so freaky [ __ ] man
the brain is a weird thing that's a
that's mind blown to me oh that's so
weird
[ __ ] that's weird that one is really
good you know that one blows my mind
every time squirtle squirrel
yeah
let's get into some real mind-blowing
business 911 predictions coming soon huh
coming soon Johnny Bravo
it started with Johnny Bravo it's a stag
Gaston that French cartoon my god
it was in Keystone Gaston there was a
book cover in 1980 oh my god are those
people just what the [ __ ] the Simpson of
course predicted it Lisa Simpson
New York nine dollars it was an inside
job even the Simpson was involved no I
knew that terrorists nuke play this card
at any time to give +10 power or
resistance to any violent group what
kind of game is this
and even the Pentagon oh my god
I need that game this the 1994 iron man
cartoon shows 9/11 Twin Towers and
Pentagon hit by planes oh my god
scary word oh my god I'm scared
no I can't believe it I can't believe I
okay
by the way this music is not edited in
this is the actual video room at what is
that a Pfeiffer rim I'll remember
remember of course remember 9 equals
equals what oh yeah
through
q33 n means airplane paper paper death
my god vision test normal vision people
will see Albert Einstein in the picture
nearsighted people will see Marilyn
Monroe
I don't whoa whoa well if I do this I
see Marilyn I'm not kidding I'm seeing
Marilyn right [ __ ] now do this
there's no one will come and get him hit
him and finish him and that's [ __ ]
cool mind equals blown you get nine dots
oh my god nine dots what the [ __ ] get it
I can't bull Vereen or too bad no
they're making out Batman would never
make out with himself
oh just six hours ago the Simpson
predicted Lady gaga
yeah cuz art is never ever you know go
on a zip line or whatever it's called no
[ __ ] way
no [ __ ] way no [ __ ] way that's
incredible that's increasing also showed
his delight I see oh my god only 98
percent of people that watch that notice
that and the rest of the 2% just wanted
to die a painful death what happens to a
canned food when you put it in lava a
question that of course everyone wants
to know and my mind is blown a can of
monster in lava Wow Wow
this is the kind of Content that is just
taking over YouTube because it asked a
questions and you have to click it to
get the answer I mean I know that's
literally the definition of click button
but it's like what you every time you
find out the answer every time the
reaction is like huh what will happen if
you lit a really hot knife into some
other [ __ ] BuzzFeed is challenging me
right now can you make it through this
post without having your mind blown put
your finger in your ear and scratch
haha
eating cheetos with chopsticks keep your
fingers clean the speed just die already
who writes this [ __ ] [ __ ] whoo-hoo
Dave stop Eric listen to your last name
okay just listen to your last name has
your mind been blown in this video then
you have to leave a like
has your mind not been blown in this
video then you have to leave two likes
also don't forget my giveaway it's in
the description all you have to do you
have to like this video
you have to bail me you have to comment
you have to Facebook Twitter Tumblr you
have to shave your head
thank you it's been my pleasure check it
also check out this video and I'll see
you on next next one that we do